PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
I DON'T WANNA ARGUE ANYMORE.
Look at you
ripping my heart out.
NNENNA WAS CONSUMED
BY FIGHTS WITH HER BOYFRIEND.
SO GET UP, JOHN.
WHEN THE GIRLS LEARNED
TO SWIRL AND TWIRL
FOR A CHURCH FASHION SHOW,
JADE STEPPED UP HER GAME...
THE WINNER IS JADE.
WHOO! ALL RIGHT!
AND TURNED UP THE ENERGY
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
THIS IS THE FIRST DAY
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE IMPRESSED ME.
YES!
BUT IT WAS LESLIE
WHO COULDN'T OVERCOME
HER ONGOING STRUGGLES
ON THE RUNWAY
AND WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
OH, MY GOD,
I GOT ANOTHER GOOD ONE.
TYRA TOLD ME WHEN I CAME UP--
SHE'S LIKE,
"YOUR PICTURE'S GREAT."
LIKE, "THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT WE WANTED."
MY KRUMPING PHOTO WAS AMAZING.
TYRA AND THE JUDGES
REALLY LIKED IT.
JOANIE, YOU TOOK THIS
WHOLE WEEK OF SOUL MODELING
AND REALLY USED IT
TO YOUR ADVANTAGE.
SO, BRAVO.
I'M REALLY, REALLY
PROUD OF MYSELF.
I FINALLY CAME OUT NUMBER ONE.
TYRA'S BEEN SAYING
THAT NONE OF MY PICTURES
HAVE BEEN DOING WELL.
BROOKE, YOU'RE THE GIRL THAT
THE JUDGES SEE YOUR PHOTOS,
AND IT DOESN'T STAND UP
TO THE GIRLS OVER HERE.
THIS WEEK,
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR ME
TO STEP IT UP AND DO WELL.
I didn't do anything
but tell you I was hurt.
I never accused you of anything
that night.
OKAY, WELL, THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT SOUNDED LIKE.
NNENNA AND HER BOYFRIEND
ARE HAVING SOME PROBLEMS.
IT ALL STARTED WHEN
SHE KISSED THE GUY VAUGHN,
THE GUY MODEL.
HE'S CALLING, CRYING,
AND IT'S KIND OF
THROWING HER OFF HER GAME.
I was feeling bad
'cause I missed you, damn it!
THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH JOHN
IS HE MISSES ME.
HE DOESN'T KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH IT,
AND I REALIZE THERE'S NOTHING
I CAN DO ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I'M HERE.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
DEFINITELY, NNENNA NEEDS TO
SOLVE HER--WHATEVER SITUATIONS
THAT SHE'S HAVING
WITH HER BOYFRIEND,
OR IT'S GONNA AFFECT HER
IN THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
WE PULL UP TO
THE STRAUSBERG AD AGENCY,
AND WE HAVE REALLY NO IDEA
WHAT WE'RE GONNA ENCOUNTER.
HELLO. WELCOME, LADIES.
I AM JEFF.
YOU ARE NOW STANDING
IN THE BUILDING OF ONE OF
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
AD AGENCIES,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MEET
THE MOST SOUGHT-AFTER
CREATIVE DIRECTOR IN THE WORLD
AS WELL.
YEAH, THAT'S RIGHT.
AND DEPRISE,
WHO YOU'RE ABOUT TO MEET,
HAS LAUNCHED MANY
A TOP MODEL'S CAREER.
I'LL BE COLLECTING
YOUR PORTFOLIOS NOW.
WHEN DEPRISE IS READY FOR YOU,
WE'LL BRING YOU BACK
ONE AT A TIME TO MEET WITH HER.
JEFF TELLS US THAT
HE'S GONNA LOOK AT OUR BOOKS
IN HOPES OF BOOKING US
A COMMERCIAL.
I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT,
YOU KNOW, WITH INTERVIEWS
AND TALKING TO PEOPLE.
DEPRISE.
- HI.
- DEPRISE.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
SO I THOUGHT
IT WAS GONNA BE GREAT.
I NEED TO SEE YOUR STOMACH,
BECAUSE YOUR STOMACH IS
LOOKING A LITTLE BIG HERE.
YOU GOTTA WORK ON THAT STOMACH
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
THE STOMACH IS--
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THAT PICTURE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT,
YOUR STOMACH'S NOT LOOKING
THAT GOOD IN PERSON, EITHER.
SHE LOOKS LIKE A TRANSVESTITE.
LOOK AT THAT FACE. COME ON.
SHE HAS ISSUES.
I THINK I'M CUTE.
I DON'T THINK I LOOK LIKE
A DRAG QUEEN.
WHAT THE GIRLS DON'T KNOW IS
I'M AN ACTRESS
AND A FORMER MODEL.
AND I'M PRETENDING TO BE
A REALLY INTENSE, MEAN
CREATIVE AGENCY DIRECTOR.
I'M GONNA GIVE THEM
SOME REALLY HARSH CRITICISM
ABOUT THEIR PHYSICAL LOOKS.
THE CHALLENGE FOR THE GIRLS
IS TO SEE IF THEY CAN HANDLE
THE BRUTAL SIDE
OF THE MODELING BUSINESS,
'CAUSE IT HAPPENS ALL THE TIME.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
WOW, I GOTTA TELL YOU,
YOU LOOK ANOREXIC
IN SOME OF THESE SHOTS.
NICE--YOU GOT A NICE LITTLE GAP
RIGHT THERE BETWEEN YOUR TEETH,
DON'T YOU?
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, I SAID, "THANK YOU."
I'M LIKE, "I THINK
SHE'S BAD-MOUTHING ME."
YOUR BOTTOM LIP IS
A LOT FULLER THAN YOUR TOP ONE.
THERE WERE A FEW THAT DEFINITELY
GOT SHOOK UP.
YOUR EARS
ARE LOOKING REALLY BIG.
THAT'S SO WEIRD.
YOU HAVE A HARD TIME
PHOTOGRAPHING YOUR NOSE.
MY NOSE?
YEAH, IN THIS PICTURE,
IT'S LOOKING HUGE.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU,
YOU LOOK REALLY OLD
IN THESE PICTURES.
- DO I?
- THIS IS FRIGHTENING.
SO HAS ANYBODY EVER TOLD YOU
THAT YOU KIND OF PHOTOGRAPH
A LITTLE MASCULINE?
IT'S A LITTLE DISTURBING,
ACTUALLY.
COULD YOU SMILE FOR ME?
UGH, OKAY.
YEAH, THAT'S NOT A STRONG POINT.
WHY ARE YOU NOT SMILING
IN ANY OF THESE PICTURES?
MAKES SOMEONE THINK
THAT YOU'RE HIDING SOMETHING.
SOME PEOPLE WILL, YOU KNOW,
TURN YOU DOWN IF YOU DON'T
HAVE PERFECT TEETH,
AND THAT HAS BEEN TRUE FOR ME.
THIS IS ONE OF
MY BEST SHOOTS TO DATE.
THIS ONE?
UGH.
JOANIE WAS VERY AFFECTED.
JOANIE HAD
A HARD TIME RECOVERING.
ALL RIGHT, HE'S GONNA TAKE
SOME POLAROIDS OF YOU.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP YOU ON FILE.
OKAY.
JUST WANT A NATURAL SMILE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE
TO SHAKE THIS OFF
AND DO YOUR JOB.
AND THEY WILL CATCH THAT
IN A POLAROID.
YOU COULD SEE THE AFFECTEDNESS
IN A LOT OF THE GIRLS.
THE SMILE PROBABLY
LOOKED FAKE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING TO SMILE ABOUT.
I JUST DIDN'T ENJOY IT
AT ALL,
AND IT'S JUST NOT A SITUATION
I PUT MYSELF IN,
AND I JUST DIDN'T LIKE
BEING THERE.
I DON'T THINK
MY STOMACH IS THAT BIG.
MY NOSE IS TOO BIG.
AS FAR AS MY GAP,
YOU CAN HANG THAT ONE UP.
THE GAP IS STAYING, SUCKER.
SHE'LL COME IN HERE--"WHAT?"
DEPRISE, NICE TO MEET YOU.
EVERYBODY WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT JADE MAY DO TO DEPRISE.
WE THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING
TO GO HEAD-TO-HEAD.
YOU PHOTOGRAPH
REALLY HARSH.
YES, EXACTLY.
MY LOOK IS VERY VERSATILE.
LIKE A DUDE.
I THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE
AN EXTRA PLUS FOR ME.
WHOO, LOOK AT THIS NOSE.
THIS IS HORRENDOUS.
YEAH, MY LOOK'S LIKE...
I KNOW.
DEPRISE, YOU KNOW,
SHE'S PRETTY CUTTHROAT.
I'VE DEALT WITH THAT TYPE
OF "CUTTHROATING-NESS."
YOU GOT A HIGH FOREHEAD, TOO,
DON'T YOU?
(chuckling)
MY FEATURES
ARE VERY PRONOUNCED.
YEAH, ALL RIGHT,
JEFF'S GONNA TAKE A COUPLE
OF POLAROIDS OF YOU.
YEAH, I HAVE, LIKE,
THIS LINE, DON'T I?
JADE OWNS WHO SHE IS.
LIKE, IF YOU CAN TAKE WHATEVER
CRITICISM'S THROWN AT YOU
AND MAKE IT POSITIVE,
YOU CAN CHANGE THE OPINION
OF THE PERSON
WHO'S TALKING TO YOU
WHO THINKS A CERTAIN WAY.
- HELLO AGAIN.
- HELLO.
HERE'S WHAT'S THE DEAL.
THE REALITY IS
OF WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON
IS THAT DEPRISE IS AN ACTRESS.
OH.
I'M SORRY.
- PHENOMENAL.
- GOOD JOB.
IT WAS VERY HARD,
AND I FELT SO GUILTY.
I DIDN'T EVEN
SEE THAT COMING.
THE CHALLENGE WAS
HOW MUCH YOU CAN TAKE CRITICISM
AND STILL DO YOUR JOB
AND TAKE A GOOD POLAROID.
I WANT TO ANNOUNCE THE WINNER,
AND THAT'S GOING TO BE...
JADE.
JADE DIDN'T SEEM
TO BE FAZED BY ANYTHING
THAT WE THREW AT HER.
SO, JADE, I WANT YOU TO CHOOSE
A FRIEND RIGHT NOW.
THIS GIRL RIGHT HERE.
THE TWO OF YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE
A SURPRISE PACKAGE AT YOUR HOME.
NOT REALLY SURPRISED
THAT JADE WINS.
SHE IS USED TO BEING HARSH,
SO I THINK SHE COULD HANDLE
SOMEONE BEING HARSH TO HER.
♪♪♪
WONDER WHAT IT COULD BE.
GO, NNENNA, GO!
SOMETHING'S IN THAT BOX!
I JUST COULDN'T
FAVOR THE FACT.
I WAS LIKE,
"WHAT IS IN THIS BOX?"
(crying)
IS HER MOM IN THERE?
(squeals and laughter)
SWEETIE.
JADE IS JUST BESIDE HERSELF
WHEN SHE REALIZES IT'S HER MOM.
(crying) MOMMY.
JADE HAD OPENED UP
AND STARTED CRYING,
AND THAT WAS REALLY SWEET.
I HADN'T SEEN THAT SIDE OF JADE
EVER BEFORE.
NNENNA IS JUST HUGGING
HER BOYFRIEND.
I KNOW, SURPRISE,
SURPRISE, HUH?
FOR A SECOND, A SPLIT SECOND,
I THOUGHT IT COULD BE
ONE OF MY SISTERS IN THE BOX.
I DON'T KNOW,
I THOUGHT THAT WAS JUST
MAYBE WISHFUL THINKING.
SO WHEN I OPENED IT
AND JOHN CAME OUT,
I FELT INDIFFERENT.
JOHN--JUST FOR HIM
TO BE HERE, IT'S GONNA BE
KIND OF DIFFICULT FOR NNENNA,
SO IT'S CAUSING TENSION.
OH, LOOK AT THE DINING ROOM.
YEAH, SO THIS IS OUR KITCHEN.
NIGEL BARKER.
- YEAH.
- NIGEL BARKER ROOM.
TODAY, YOU KNOW, ME AND NNENNA
GOT PACKAGES.
YOU KNOW, MY PACKAGE WAS MY MOM,
AND NNENNA'S PACKAGE
WAS HER BOYFRIEND.
YOU SEE MY HAIR?
YEAH, I LOVE IT. I LOVE IT.
MY MOM DOES ENERGY WORK.
SHE, YOU KNOW, PULLS ENERGY
THROUGH THE UNIVERSE
THROUGH HER HANDS.
♪♪♪
I WROTE SOMETHING TODAY,
AND I'D LIKE TO SHARE IT.
HEAVEN AND HELL,
EARTH, POWER, WIND, FORCE,
MAKE ME LISTEN, AND MY STRENGTH
WILL BE MY SOURCE.
SIT DOWN,
I HAVE A LOT TO TELL YOU.
- OH, REALLY?
- MM-HMM.
LET ME TELL YOU HOW IT STARTED.
I KISSED VAUGHN.
ON THE PHONE, I TOLD JOHN
I KISSED A MALE MODEL,
BUT NOW I'M THINKING
HOW TO FRAME THE WHOLE SITUATION
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK THAT BAD.
WE HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH MALE MODELS, RIGHT?
HE, LIKE, HE KISSED ME
ON MY BOTTOM LIP.
BUT I DIDN'T, LIKE, TURN AWAY.
I WAS JUST THERE, LIKE,
I WAS LOOKING AT THE CAMERA,
- AND I STILL TOOK THE KISS.
- LET HIM DO IT?
YEAH,
THAT'S ALL THAT HAPPENED.
NOTHING ELSE, I PROMISE.
NO, UH-UH,
YOU DON'T GET OFF THAT EASY.
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T
LET THAT HAPPEN AGAIN.
HUH? BABY?
TYRA MAIL!
"SOME SAY MODELS
ARE BRAINLESS LIVING DOLLS.
ARE YOU? TYRA."
YES, I AM, HA HA!
♪♪♪
SO I GOT A LITTLE STORY
FOR Y'ALL.
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE KID,
MY SISTER USED TO
GET ME IN SO MUCH TROUBLE
'CAUSE I USED TO STEAL
HER DOLLS ALL THE TIME.
THAT'S BECAUSE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT DOLLS,
THEY'VE GOT PERFECT HAIR.
SO TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE
ACTUALLY GONNA BE DOLLS.
OH!
YOU'RE ACTUALLY DOING A SHOOT
FOR PANTENE
BECAUSE PANTENE PRO-V
GIVES YOU PERFECT HAIR.
- HI, GIRLS.
- HI.
I'M HERE FROM PANTENE
TO USE SOME PRODUCTS ON YOU
BACK THERE AND MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE HEALTHY, SHINY,
BEAUTIFUL HAIR.
WE HAD TO BRING SOMEBODY BACK
WHO WAS ONE OF
OUR FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPHERS.
HE WAS YOUR FIRST PHOTOGRAPHER
ON YOUR FIRST PHOTO SHOOT.
PASCAL, COME ON OUT HERE.
YAY!
HI, GIRLS, HOW ARE YOU?
I'M HAPPY TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
OKAY, LADIES.
SO FOR THIS SHOOT, JOANIE,
YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A VENTRILOQUIST DOLL.
COOL.
SARA, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A TEEN DOLL.
FURONDA, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A RAG DOLL.
(laughing)
JADE, THERE IS ONLY ONE PERSON
YOU COULD BE--
A MANNEQUIN DOLL.
BROOKE, YOU'RE GONNA BE
A GLAM DOLL.
AND, NNENNA, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A BABY DOLL.
DANIELLE, YOU ARE GOING TO BE
A MARIONETTE.
ALL RIGHT,
POP INTO HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND WE ARE READY TO START.
♪♪♪
WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS IN NOW
BEFORE WE BRAID IT JUST TO ADD
A LITTLE BIT OF HOLD.
IT'S AN INTENSIVE
OIL SHEEN SPRAY.
YEAH, IT'S NICE. IT DOES.
I MEAN, IT'S GREAT.
♪♪♪
SO, JOANIE, THIS IS GONNA BE
YOUR PUPPET MASTER TODAY.
HIS NAME'S ALEX.
HI. NICE TO MEET YOU.
YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE SITTING ON HIS KNEE.
OKAY.
AND HE'S GONNA BE
YOUR PUPPET MASTER.
EVERYBODY'S KIND OF LIKE,
"DANG, YOU GET A MALE MODEL."
I MEAN, CAN WE SHARE?
♪♪♪
HE'S A HOTTIE WITH A BODY.
IT WAS NICE EYE CANDY FOR TODAY.
NEW FRAGRANCE.
OH, I LOVE PANTENE.
TEXTURED SHINING POMADE.
IT CREATES TEXTURE, SEPARATES
AND ADDS SHINE.
I THINK PANTENE
GOT THE NOBEL PEACE PRIZE
FOR THIS.
WE'RE GONNA ADD
A LITTLE HAIRSPRAY HERE
TO BOOST SHINE,
AND IT ALSO GIVES A GREAT HOLD.
OH, YOU LOOK SO CUTE!
WAIT, LET'S SEE. TURN AROUND.
THAT IS INSANE.
♪♪♪
COME ON, GIRLS.
YAY, I'M LUCKY.
(chuckles)
JOANIE, PRETEND YOU'RE IN
A TRAVELING CIRCUS,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
♪♪♪
YOU'RE LOOKING GOOD.
DO SOME WITH A SMILE.
OKAY.
I DIDN'T WANT TO SMILE.
I TRAINED MY MOUTH BEFORE
TO KIND OF COVER MY TEETH.
DON'T LOOK CRAZY.
JUST MAKE IT PRETTY.
ALL THE GIRLS HERE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, STRAIGHT TEETH.
I FEEL THIS IS THE ONLY THING
HOLDING ME BACK.
GOOD JOB, GUYS.
EXCELLENT.
(humming)
OKAY, AND SARA, TEENAGE DOLLS,
THEY'RE A LITTLE MORE...
- THEY'RE NOT LIKE...
- SASSY?
YEAH, THEY'RE MORE SASSY,
THEY'RE MORE IN YOUR FACE,
KIND OF LIKE, "WHAT?"
LIKE, ATTITUDE, SASS.
GOOD.
SARA,
DOLLS ARE A LITTLE TIGHTER.
THEY WOULDN'T BE PACKAGED
INTO A BOX LIKE THIS.
ME AND SARA BOTH HAD TO SHOOT
IN A BOX, SO I WONDER IF
I'M GONNA HAVE
DIFFICULTY WITH IT AS WELL.
OKAY, LOOK AT THIS, BROOKE.
RAISE YOUR HEAD A LITTLE BIT.
ONE, TWO.
KEEP GOING. YOU'RE PERFECT.
BROOKE, WHAT'S GOING ON IN
YOUR HEAD WHILE YOU SHOOT THIS?
TELL ME. TALK TO ME.
I'M SUPPOSED TO LOOK
LIKE A DOLL?
YEAH, YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO LOOK LIKE A DOLL,
BUT YOU'RE GLAMOUR DOLL.
YOU'RE FABULOUS.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
PRETEND YOU'RE BEING
A BIT OF AN EXHIBITIONIST
FOR YOUR BOYFRIEND.
PLEASE TURN VERY SLIGHTLY.
ARE YOU REALLY THINKING
ABOUT YOUR BOYFRIEND
RIGHT NOW,
STANDING IN FRONT OF YOU NAKED?
SOMETHING. PLEASE.
I'M BECOMING
MORE AND MORE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE I'M NOT GETTING
ANY POSITIVE FEEDBACK.
IT'S ALL NEGATIVE.
BROOKE, THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU'RE NOT SURE ABOUT.
WHAT I DO NEED YOU TO DO
IS WORK ON BEING COMFORTABLE
IN YOUR SKIN.
IF YOU KEEP THINKING
YOU'RE GONNA BE CUT,
YOU'RE GONNA BE CUT.
YOU CAN'T THINK ABOUT THAT
WHEN YOU'RE HERE.
DANIELLE, YOU FEELING IT?
- I AM FEELING IT.
- YOU GONNA WORK IT FOR ME?
I'M FEELING IT. YES.
THE HEAT IS ON BECAUSE
I'VE NEVER HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
LIKE THIS BEFORE
WHERE, YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE TO EVOKE, LIKE,
BEING SOMETHING ELSE
BUT STILL REMEMBERING
THAT WE'RE A MODEL.
OKAY, PERFECT.
COME ON. YES.
SHE'S FEELING THIS.
SHE'S GIVING ME A PUPPET,
BUT A MODEL.
LAST FRAME.
♪♪♪
OOH, YOU'RE LOOKING SO EERIE,
LIKE A REAL MANNEQUIN, JADE.
THAT'S THE IDEA, RIGHT?
YOUR BODY LANGUAGE IS GENIUS.
JAY--HE IS SO IMPRESSED
WITH ME.
AND I'M JUST LIKE, "THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, GOD."
I THINK YOU'RE DOING
A GOOD JOB.
THANK YOU.
KEEP GOING. CHANGE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING
DIFFERENT TODAY?
THIS IS PROBABLY
THE BEST YOU'VE DONE.
THANK YOU.
FURONDA WAS NOT
SELF-EVALUATING,
AND SHE IMPROVISED
FRAME AFTER FRAME AFTER FRAME.
IT WAS JUST A PLEASURE
TO WATCH HER.
NNENNA'S ON SET.
YOU GONNA HAVE FUN WITH THIS?
- MM-HMM.
- YOU SURE? YOU PROMISE?
- YES.
- DON'T DISAPPOINT ME.
RAISE YOUR HEAD
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I NEVER REALLY WAS
A BIG FAN OF DOLLS
WHILE I WAS GROWING UP,
SO TRYING TO ACT LIKE A DOLL
IS AWKWARD.
HOW DOES A BABY DOLL
LOOK TO YOU?
HAPPY.
THAT'S IT.
THINK ABOUT JOHN
BACK AT THE HOUSE.
'CAUSE MEN MAKE YOU SMILE.
NNENNA, YOU THINKING
ABOUT YOUR MAN?
YEAH.
NNENNA CONTINUES
TO HOLD BACK HER MOTIONS.
LAST FRAME.
I THINK IT'S REALLY HURTING HER.
SO YOU KNOW TODAY
WE'RE DEALING WITH PERFECTION
AND BEAUTY.
SO TYRA HAS AN EXTRA SPECIAL
TREAT FOR YOU GUYS.
WE'RE GONNA SEND YOU GUYS
TO AN AMAZING DENTIST
HERE IN L.A.
OH, WOW.
THANKS, JAY. THANKS, TYRA.
NOW FOR MOST OF YOU,
THAT JUST MEANS
WHITENING YOUR TEETH.
BUT FOR JOANIE AND DANIELLE,
THE DENTIST IS GONNA
DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT SNAGGLETOOTH
AND FOR THAT GAP, TOO,
AND PERFECT YOUR SMILE.
(crying)
OH.
LITTLE EMOTIONAL RIGHT NOW.
IT'S OKAY, BABY.
WHAT'S WRONG, JOANIE?
YOU'RE HAPPY, RIGHT?
THEY'RE TEARS OF JOY.
WHOO-HOO! THAT'S SO COOL.
OH.
I COULD NEVER AFFORD
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
IF WE COULD GO TO THE DENTIST
FOR A CHECKUP EVERY YEAR,
WE WERE LUCKY.
I NEVER GOT BRACES
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU WANNA
GRAB YOUR STUFF?
- YEAH.
- YAY!
(elevator bell dings)
♪♪♪
GOOD AFTERNOON, JOANIE.
TYRA HAS ASKED TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO
TO IMPROVE ON THE SMILE.
SO WE HAVE TO TAKE SOME X-RAYS.
WE'LL TAKE SOME PHOTOS.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT VENEERS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE?
- THEY'RE A TEETH CAP.
- YEP.
BASICALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS
EACH TOOTH IS FILED DOWN,
AND A PORCELAIN OVERLAY
IS PLACED ON TOP OF IT.
WE WILL REMOVE THESE FOUR.
- TODAY?
- WE'LL REMOVE 'EM TODAY.
OHH!
YOU KNOW, KEEP IN MIND
THAT TONIGHT IS
JUST THE FIRST STEP.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA LIKE
HOW YOU LOOK.
HOW YOU FEEL.
WE'RE GONNA GET YOU BACK
TOMORROW, THOUGH, AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A NICE SET
TEMPORARIES READY TO GO FOR YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA
LOOK AND FEEL FANTASTIC.
- COOL.
- READY TO START?
YEAH.
THIS IS SOMETHING, LIKE,
I'LL NEVER FORGET.
AND IT'S DEFINITELY
GONNA CHANGE MY LIFE.
DANIELLE,
SO IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
YOU DON'T LIKE ABOUT YOUR SMILE?
MY GUMS ARE RECEDING UP HERE,
LIKE ON MY FRONT TOOTH.
WHAT ABOUT THE GAP?
I LOVE MY GAP.
THE GAP--I LOVE THE GAP.
THE SIGNATURE GAP
IS STAYING IN MY MOUTH.
THAT'S WHO I AM.
TYRA--SHE WANTS EVERYONE
TO GO THROUGH THE 1-HOUR
WHITENING PROCEDURE.
WOULD YOU LIKE YOUR TEETH
A LITTLE BIT WHITER?
YEAH, DEFINITELY.
OKAY.
♪♪♪
I HAD THESE, LIKE,
CATARACT NEON SUNGLASSES ON.
I CANNOT WAIT TO GET
MY TEETH WHITENED, YOU KNOW.
IT WAS COOL!
WE'RE DONE.
THEY LOOK A LOT WHITER.
THEY ARE.
YOU KNOW,
AFTER THE WHITENING PROCESS,
YOU KNOW, I LOOK IN THE MIRROR.
I'M LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
MY TEETH ARE WHITE!
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT!"
MY WHOLE BODY IS TINGLING.
NICE, BIG DEEP BREATHS
THROUGH YOUR NOSE.
♪♪♪
- WOW, DUDE!
- GOOD GOD!
THANK GOD.
I FELT THAT ONE, DUDE.
ARE MY TEETH THAT LONG?
(laughs)
THE SNAGGLETOOTH IS NO LONGER.
THIS PROCESS WAS A LOT OF WORK
AND A LOT OF STRESS.
THINK WE'LL BE
HERE ALL NIGHT?
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES.
NOT ONLY THAT, BUT I HAVE TO
GET UP IN THE MORNING
AND BE A MODEL.
(suctioning)
(drilling)
I'M GOING TO GO HAVE
ALL MY FRONT 12 TEETH
GRINDED DOWN TO PENCIL POINTS.
♪♪♪
I'VE BEEN IN
THAT DENTIST'S OFFICE
FOR 12 HOURS.
I HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT
ALL DAY TOMORROW.
LOOK AT MY TEETH.
♪♪♪
I LEFT THERE LAST NIGHT
AT 5:30 IN THE MORNING.
Oh, brother.
I HAVE HILLBILLY TEETH.
I'M EXHAUSTED RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE I WAS AT
THE DENTIST'S OFFICE
TILL 5:30 IN THE MORNING.
I HAVE TO COMPETE TODAY,
AND I CAN'T EVEN TALK.
You're fine.
Forget your mouth right now.
Now it's time to compete.
I WAS STILL VERY HAPPY
TO SEE MY BOYFRIEND,
'CAUSE HE REALLY NEEDED
TO SEE ME.
SO I THINK HIM COMING
WAS A REALLY GOOD THING.
IT'S GONNA HELP HIM.
SPREAD THE LOVE.
GOOD LUCK TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
JADE'S REACTION
TO HER MOM BEING THERE--
THIS WHOLE KIND OF HARD,
OVERLY CONFIDENT EXTERIOR
MELTS.
SHE NEEDS TO SHOW THE JUDGES
THAT SIDE OF JADE.
- LOVE YOU. BYE.
- I LOVE YOU.
- BYE.
HE MISSES ME,
AND HE'S EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT,
BUT I HAVEN'T TAKEN MYSELF
OUT OF THE COMPETITION
FOR A MOMENT
BECAUSE I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
THAT WAS SUCH A TREAT.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
"THERE'S NO LIFEGUARD ON DUTY,
BUT THERE ARE DI-VAS."
OR DIVAS.
DIVERS? LIFEGUARDS?
SO IT HAS SOMETHING
TO DO WITH WATER.
I KNOW, BUT I'M JUST SAYING
INSTEAD OF "DIVAS,"
IT COULD BE "DI-VAS."
OH.
♪♪♪
WE ARRIVE AT CLUB MOOD.
WE WALK INTO CLUB MOOD,
AND WE SEE THE INFAMOUS
JANICE DICKINSON,
AND WE ALSO SEE EVA PIGFORD,
WHO WAS THE WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
CYCLE THREE.
EVA.
(screams)
THIS IS SO UNREAL.
WHAT'S UP, EVERYBODY?
HELLO.
MY NAME IS MARC ECKO.
I'M THE FOUNDER
AND HEAD DESIGNER
FOR RED BY MARC ECKO.
IT'S A NEW ACCESSORY COLLECTION
THAT I'M LAUNCHING.
I HAPPEN TO BE DOING
A SHOOT TODAY
FOR "ELLE GIRL" MAGAZINE.
AND I'M HERE WITH
A COUPLE OF MY FRIENDS
THAT YOU MIGHT KNOW,
SO LET'S GO MEET 'EM.
I'M REALLY EXCITED, 'CAUSE,
I MEAN, I'VE NEVER GOT
TO MEET EVA.
I THINK I ADMIRE HER THE MOST
OUT OF ANY OF THE GIRLS
THAT HAVE WON "TOP MODEL."
IT'S GOOD,
I MEAN, UM,
YOU GUYS ARE LEARNING, LIKE, THE
BIGGEST LESSON NOW.
IF YOU EXUDE CONFIDENCE,
AND IF YOU HAVE CONFIDENCE,
I THINK YOU HELP YOURSELF OUT.
WHEN YOU WALK IN THERE,
IT'S LIKE,
"OKAY, I CAN DO THIS."
YOU HAVE TO HAVE IT HERE.
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING
I CAN STRESS.
STAY BEAUTIFUL, GIRLS.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
SOMETHING THAT STUCK OUT
TO ME FROM WHAT SHE SAID IS
HOW YOU NEED TO BE CONFIDENT.
AND EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT,
YOU NEED TO SHOW, LIKE,
PRETEND THAT YOU ARE.
SHE'S BACK!
JANICE.
SHE'S BACK.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT...
♪ DUN-DUN-DUN-DUN ♪
THE DARK SIDE OF MODELING.
THE UGLY SIDE
OF MODELING EXISTS.
THE UGLY SIDE OF MODELING
WILL GET THEM IF THEY DON'T KNOW
HOW TO PREVENT IT.
BIG ZERO NO-NO IS "ALCOHOL,"
WHICH IS MY BIG THING.
EXAMPLE--WHEN I WAS HIRED FOR
MY FIRST VALENTINO FASHION SHOW,
I GOT TO THE BOOKING.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CHAMPAGNE
BACKSTAGE.
I KNOCKED BACK
TWO GLASSES OF CHAMPAGNE.
AS SOON AS I WALKED DOWN
THE END OF THE RUNWAY,
I KEPT WALKING,
AND I WALKED OFF THE RUNWAY
AND DID A LOOP-DI-LOOP INTO
THE LAPS OF SOPHIA LOREN
AND MARCELLO MASTROIANNI.
SO I SEVERED A HUGE CAREER
WITH VALENTINO.
I'M GONNA LET YOU GUYS
ASK ME A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
ANYTHING YOU WANT.
HOW EASY OR HARD
WAS IT FOR YOU TO KEEP
YOUR RELATIONSHIP AND FAMILY
WHILE STILL KEEPING
YOUR CAREER GOING?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
I HAVE AN 11-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTER,
AN 18-YEAR-OLD SON.
WHEN I'M WORKING,
I AM SO GUILTY ABOUT
HAVING MY CHILDREN
NOT WITH ME.
IT'S THE WORST.
THAT DOES HIT HOME FOR ME,
'CAUSE I ALWAYS THINK
TO THE FUTURE
HOW I WOULD HAVE A FAMILY
AND HAVE A CAREER.
BEWARE, TAKE CARE, SEE YA!
BYE!
THIS IS DEFINITELY
A ONCE IN A LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
THAT I'M NOT GONNA GET BACK
IF I THROW IT AWAY
BECAUSE OF JOHN.
♪♪♪
AFTER TALKING WITH JANICE,
WE GO TO A STUDIO,
AND WE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO EXPECT.
SO WALKING OUTSIDE,
I KIND OF FEEL LIKE,
"WHAT THE HELL'S GOING ON?"
SO I'M WALKING, I'M WALKING,
I'M WALKING.
THEN I SEE TYRA.
- HELLO, JADE.
- HOW ARE YOU?
ALL RIGHT, SO, JADE,
EVERYBODY THINKS MODELING
IS GLAMOUR AND FABULOUS
AND BEAUTIFUL,
BUT THERE'S AN UGLY SIDE.
YES.
AND I'VE SHED
SO MANY TEARS IN THIS INDUSTRY.
SO TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
- DIRECTED BY ME.
- YES, MA'AM.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO BE CRYING
- OKAY.
- IN THE PHOTO SHOOT, OKAY?
I GOT A LITTLE TOOL HERE.
OH, OKAY.
- AND THIS IS TEAR STICK.
- AWESOME.
I'M GONNA PUT THIS ON YOUR EYES,
AND THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE YOU CRY.
OKAY.
OKAY, IT'S GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF A BITE TO IT.
SO...
CAN YOU FEEL THAT RIGHT HERE?
MM-MM.
THEY PUT, LIKE,
A STICK OF VAPOR ON OUR EYES.
SO OUR EYES WOULD TEAR.
AT FIRST, I DIDN'T FEEL IT.
PUT IT, LIKE, ON MY EYE, DUDE.
LIKE, GET IT ON THERE.
ALL RIGHT.
I SAID, "SUTAN,
GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT MORE.
COME ON, GIVE ME
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
FEEL THAT ALREADY?
TEARS ARE COMIN'.
ALL RIGHT, JIM.
SO, JADE, IT'S NOT GONNA BE,
LIKE, ACTING.
- OKAY.
- IT'S JUST LIKE, "I'M SO SAD,
BUT, GOD, I'M GORGEOUS."
- I GOT IT, BABY.
- ALL RIGHT.
YEAH, LOOK ABOVE HIS HEAD...
LIKE THIS, LIKE, OH.
OH, BEAUTIFUL,
JUST LIKE THAT.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND OPEN.
ALL RIGHT, WE GOT IT.
COOL, THAT WAS AWESOME.
IT'LL MAKE YOU TEAR UP.
ARE YOU READY, MISS DANIELLE?
YEAH, I'M DEFINITELY CRYING.
IT'S SUPPOSED TO BURN.
SO, TYRA, WHAT IS THIS
YOU PUT IN MY EYE?
(laughs)
WHAT IS THIS?
I'M CRYING BECAUSE,
LIKE, THE MENTHOL,
IT'S STEADY MAKING
MY TEARS FLOW,
BUT I WANT TO SCREAM.
IT WAS REALLY BAD.
OKAY, HERE WE GO.
I'M GONNA POUR IN, OKAY?
FEEL A LITTLE BETTER?
- NO, THAT'S BETTER.
- BETTER? OKAY.
BUT ONCE I GOT UP THERE,
YOU KNOW, I GOT INTO THE ZONE.
GOOD, RELAX YOUR FACE.
THINK OLD HOLLYWOOD MOVIE STAR.
NOW I WANT YOU TO PUSH IT
AND GET OUT
OF YOUR COMFORT ZONE, LIKE THIS.
- "I'M SO SAD..."
- YEAH.
"AND I'M SO INNOCENT."
I NAILED MY SHOOT
AFTER I GOT PAST THE PAIN.
(laughs)
WELL, THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED
TO THINK, THOUGH,
WHILE WE'RE SHOOTING YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ACT THAT MUCH.
THE TEARS ARE ON YOUR FACE,
SO THAT'S ALREADY DOING
HALF THE WORK, OKAY?
I WANT YOU TO WATCH ME, 'CAUSE--
- OKAY.
- IT'S NOT LIKE--
'CAUSE WHAT YOU'RE DOIN'
IS YOU'RE DOIN' REAL TEARS.
YOU'RE GOIN', LIKE...
SO LOOK AT THE PICTURE
THAT I'M CREATING.
TYRA'S A WONDERFUL DIRECTOR,
AND SHE WAS JUST GIVING ME
THOUGHTS TO PUT IN MY HEAD.
IT'S MORE LIKE... (sighs)
SO I TRIED TO GIVE TYRA
WHAT SHE ASKED FOR.
PUSH YOUR BODY FORWARD AGAIN,
LIKE, INTO IT, INTO IT.
FURROW YOUR BROW
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
THINK SAD.
LESS SEXY AND MORE
BAD LITTLE GIRL.
I'M DOING MY BEST,
AND ACTUALLY, THEY'RE,
LIKE, "LOOK SAD,"
BECAUSE TYRA IS TELLING ME
I KINDA LOOK SEXY...
NOW THINK SAD.
AND IT REALLY WASN'T WORKING.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA.
YEAH, THERE YOU GO,
RELAX YOUR FACE,
RELAX YOUR FACE.
THINK OLD HOLLYWOOD MOVIE STAR.
TEARS.
THERE YOU GO.
IT SURPRISED ME THAT
THE EMOTION CAME OUT.
THE ONLY TIME I GET
REALLY VULNERABLE AND WEAK
IS WHEN I THINK ABOUT MY FAMILY.
WHAT IS IT, NNENNA?
(crying)
WHAT IS IT?
I DON'T NORMALLY CRY.
BUT THE FAKE TEARS
MADE SOMETHING REAL COME?
DO YOU FEEL
LIKE A RELEASE, MAYBE?
OKAY, GIVE ME A HUG.
I'M KINDA RELIEVED,
BECAUSE I, YOU KNOW,
I'VE BEEN TEMPTED
TO GIVE IN TO CRYING,
BUT I'VE JUST BEEN
SO STUBBORN ABOUT IT.
SARA, SO I NEED YOU TO THINK
OLD MOVIE STAR LIKE YOU'RE SAD
AND YOU'RE CRYING.
NICE, SARA.
CRAZY THAT I'M GETTING,
YOU KNOW, HAVE A ONE-ON-ONE
LESSON FROM TYRA BANKS
ON MODELING.
STICK YOUR NECK OUT.
THERE YOU GO.
- GOOD.
- ALL RIGHT, YAY!
HANDS, LIKE, MORE,
LIKE, SOFTER, OH...
AND THEN ON YOUR HEAD,
LIKE YOU HAVE A HEADACHE, OH.
OVERALL TODAY,
I FEEL HORRIBLY SICK,
AND I KNOW I HAVE TO GO BACK
TO THE DENTIST TONIGHT.
I JUST AM NOT, LIKE,
IN THE MOOD FOR IT.
OH, WAIT.
SO IS SOMETHING IN THE EYE,
OR IS IT THE GLYCERIN?
I THINK THE GLYCERIN
GOT IN IT.
I'M IN SO MUCH PAIN,
BUT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO
GO THROUGH PAIN, YOU KNOW,
TO BE BEAUTIFUL.
CLOSE YOUR EYES IN BETWEEN,
AND OPEN.
NICE, NICE, NICE.
YOU MADE 'EM CRY,
AND YOU DIDN'T TELL 'EM
TO GO HOME.
(laughs) EXACTLY.
♪♪♪
JOANIE, LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AND SEE HOW YOU ARE DOIN'.
I GET TO GO
TO DR. FALCON'S OFFICE.
THIS PROCESS OF GETTING VENEERS,
IT'S A LOT OF WORK
AND A LOT OF STRESS.
YOU'RE PUTTIN' 'EM ON NOW?
YES, SO JUST BEAR WITH ME,
ONCE IT SNAPS INTO PLACE.
WE'RE ALL DONE.
LOOK WHAT YOU GOT NOW.
(gasps) GOODNESS, WOW.
YOU LIKE THE WAY IT LOOKS?
I LOVE IT,
IT'S SO NICE.
I FEEL A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE STILL, SMILING,
BECAUSE I'M NOT USED TO THIS--
THIS KIND OF SMILE YET.
THANK YOU.
MY PLEASURE,
IT'S MY PLEASURE.
NOW I DON'T SEE ANYTHING
HOLDING ME BACK.
WHAT YOU WENT THROUGH
HAS FELLED MANY A LARGE MAN.
TOP MODELS
HAVE TO BE TOUGH.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SIX WILL CONTINUE ON
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
TYRA."
AND THEN THERE WERE SIX.
I FEEL THAT MY PHOTO SHOOT
DIDN'T GO THAT WELL.
THINK SAD.
SO I JUST FEEL THAT
I MAY BE GOING HOME
BECAUSE OF THIS.
I DON'T FEEL LIKE
I'M THE WEAKEST PERSON HERE.
I THINK MY PERFORMANCE
IS PRETTY AVERAGE.
THIS IS DEFINITELY
A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY
THAT I'M NOT GONNA GET BACK
IF I THROW IT AWAY
BECAUSE I'M DISTRACTED BY JOHN.
♪♪♪
WELCOME, LADIES.
HEY.
OR SHOULD I SAY,
"WELCOME, LADIES,"
'CAUSE YOU LEARNED ABOUT
THE UGLY SIDE OF MODELING
THIS WEEK,
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
ONE OF YOU WILL HAVE TO GO HOME.
YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT WITH
TOP INTERNATIONAL MODELING
MANAGEMENT COMPANY, FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY A PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT I LOVE SO MUCH,
AND HE'S WORLD-RENOWNED--
MR. GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
ALL RIGHTY, AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW, THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND THE SEXY MISS J., RUNWAY
DIVA TEACHER EXTRAORDINAIRE,
AND THE SEXY
FASHION ICON, TWIGGY,
AND OUR LOVELY GUEST JUDGE,
MR. PASCAL DEMEESTER,
AND HE WAS YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
THIS WEEK.
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
FURONDA, YOU'RE FIRST.
ALL RIGHTY, SO FURONDA, YOU DID
TWO PHOTO SHOOTS THIS WEEK.
YOU DID ONE WHERE I SPOKE TO YOU
ABOUT THE UGLY SIDE OF MODELING,
AND SOMETIMES IT GETS SO UGLY,
THAT IT JUST
MAKES YOU WANNA CRY.
SO HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
OOH.
WHEN THE COMPETITION STARTED,
I WASN'T SURE
YOU WERE PHOTOGENIC,
AND AS THE WEEKS HAVE GONE ON,
YOU'VE JUST GROWN.
AND THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR OFTEN
IN A TOP MODEL,
IS SOMEONE THAT DEVELOPS.
ALL RIGHTY, FURONDA,
YOU ALSO HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE A DOLL.
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
- FABULOUS.
- I LOVE IT.
WELL, FURONDA,
THIS IS PROBABLY YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE THING IS IS THAT
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE BODY
TO BE A RAG DOLL.
THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
FOR A GIRL WHO CRIES A LOT,
I THINK THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
A STRONGER PICTURE.
BROOKE, FOR ME, IT JUST
WASN'T, LIKE, SO PLEASURABLE
ON SET, BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE SO IN YOUR HEAD,
AND YOU'RE SO NERVOUS.
SO I FELT LIKE
I HAD TO KIND OF TELL YOU,
"PULL YOUR FACE HERE. DO THIS."
AND YOU TENSE UP.
I KNOW IN MY HEART AND SOUL
THAT YOU'VE GOT IT IN YOU,
AND THIS PHOTO,
YOU JUST HAVEN'T GOT IT.
- I AGREE WITH YOU.
- AND IT'S SO FRUSTRATING.
I WANNA COME AND SHAKE YOU.
I WON'T.
IT'S FUNNY, BROOKE,
BECAUSE WEEK TO WEEK,
I LOOK AT YOU, AND I'M LIKE,
"WOW, I LOVE HER FACE.
IT'S VERY ANIMALISTIC.
HER EYES ARE SMOLDERING,"
AND THE FRUSTRATION
OF GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM IS,
YEAH, THERE WERE NO DOLL SHOTS.
IT WAS JUST MODEL POSEY
AND GLAMOUR TYPE OF DOLL.
YOU KNOW, IT'S THE DOLL POSES.
IT'S--IT'S CERTAIN THINGS,
AND THIS WAS THE EASIEST ONE.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
MM.
IT WAS A JOY
WORKING WITH YOU,
BECAUSE YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW TO MAKE ANGUISH
BUT STILL STAY PRETTY.
AND THAT COULD BE
IN AN ART BOOK, OR IT COULD BE
IN A FASHION MAGAZINE.
THANK YOU.
SHE WAS
A VENTRILOQUIST'S DUMMY.
(laughs)
LOOK AT YOUR LEGS.
THEY'RE, LIKE, KIND OF BROKEN
ALMOST LIKE THEY'RE WOODEN
OR SOMETHING.
YOU NAILED IT,
AND YOUR TEETH, BY THE WAY,
- LOOK A LOT BETTER.
- THANK YOU.
GIVE US A SMILE.
SHE GOT HER TEETH FIXED.
DID YOU GO THROUGH
A LOT OF PAIN?
ONE DAY,
I WAS THERE FOR 12 HOURS.
LAST NIGHT, I WAS THERE
FOR SIX HOURS.
WELL, WELL DONE, YOU.
YOU LOOK SO MUCH BETTER.
THANK YOU.
OKAY, UP NEXT IS DANIELLE.
SO, DANIELLE,
YOU WENT TO THE DENTIST,
BUT YOU REFUSED TO HAVE
YOUR GAP CLOSED.
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU CAN
HAVE A COVERGIRL CONTRACT
WITH A GAP IN YOUR MOUTH?
YES, WHY NOT?
THIS IS ALL PEOPLE SEE.
IT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
IT'S NOT MARKETABLE.
JUST A LITTLE BIT
IS OKAY, BUT I DON'T WANNA...
COMPLETELY CLOSE IT.
WELL, I GUESS SHE JUST
LEFT THE "GAP" WIDE OPEN
FOR ANOTHER GIRL, BABY.
I AGREE.
I DON'T SEE ANY DEEP EMOTION.
I CERTAINLY DON'T SEE SADNESS.
YOU ALREADY KNOW YOU CAN TAKE
A PRETTY PICTURE.
IT'S EFFORTLESS FOR YOU.
BUT I NEVER GOT THAT TRUE,
DEEP, STRONG EMOTION.
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO BE A DOLL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
YOU'VE DEFINITELY GOT
THE BODY LANGUAGE DOWN,
WHICH IS SO IMPORTANT,
IT'S KEY.
LET ME SEE A CLOSE-UP.
LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S A BLANK EYE, BUT THERE'S
SOME INTENSITY IN THERE.
THANKS.
UP NEXT IS JADE.
NICE ICY ANGUISH THERE.
IT'S ANOTHER
VERY BEAUTIFUL PHOTOGRAPH.
THAT'S REALLY, YOU KNOW,
IT'S PAIN, IT'S REAL.
'CAUSE I'VE SUFFERED--
I'VE BEEN--EXCUSE ME.
JADE, ONE THING--
I DON'T MEAN
TO QUESTION EMOTION,
BUT WHEN YOU TEARED UP,
I DIDN'T BELIEVE IT.
IT SEEMED LIKE
BAD ACTING TO ME.
MM-HMM, MM-HMM,
I DO AGREE WITH YOU.
YEAH, I AGREE WITH YOU.
I WASN'T LOOKING AT YOU,
I DECIDED TO LOOK BEHIND YOU,
AND I NOTICED SEVERAL GIRLS,
EYES ROLLED IN THEIR HEAD.
I KNOW, YOU KNOW,
HOW I AM INSIDE, AND THAT'S WHY
I'M DEALING WITH SO MUCH--
"TORN-NESS."
I THINK YOU THINK THAT
THE OPPOSITE OF ARROGANCE
IS SUBMISSIVE AND SAD.
AND THE OPPOSITE OF ARROGANCE
FOR US
IS EXUBERANT AND GRATEFUL.
IT'S NOT, "OH, YES, TYRA,
I'M SAD."
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS.
OKAY.
NOW, I THINK--
I THINK THAT'S EXCELLENT.
YOU DO LOOK LIKE A MANNEQUIN.
LOOKING AT YOUR FILM,
I WAS BLOWN AWAY.
AND YOU'VE PULLED IT OFF.
WELL, THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS SARA.
OH, SHE LOOKS LIKE
SHE HAS A HEADACHE.
IT DOESN'T EVOKE
REALLY CRYING OR MISERY TO ME.
IT'S SORT OF MORE
SLIGHTLY NUTS.
SHE WAS A TEEN DOLL.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE
THINGS LIKE THIS.
SARA, IT SEEMS THAT YOU'RE NOT
PASSIONATE ABOUT MODELING.
WHAT DO YOU
HAVE TO SAY ABOUT THAT?
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY THAT
I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
IN JUST DOING THIS,
I'VE KIND OF DISCOVERED
A DIFFERENT SIDE OF MYSELF THAT
I NEVER REALLY KNEW WAS THERE,
AND MORE AND MORE, I'M BECOMING
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT, SO...
ALL RIGHTY,
LAST BUT NOT LEAST, NNENNA.
WHEN I LOOK AT THIS SHOT,
I FEEL THAT THE CHIN
IS SO LARGE IN THE PICTURE,
THAT IF YOU BROUGHT IT DOWN
A LITTLE BIT, IT WOULD--
IT WOULD JUST LOOK A LITTLE MORE
SORT OF GENTLE.
I-I DON'T THINK
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE, LIKE,
MODEL-Y BEAUTIFUL,
OUT OF ALL THE PICTURES,
THIS IS THE ONE I FEEL THE MOST.
WELL, I DON'T THINK
SHE SUITS THE BABY DOLL LOOK.
WHATEVER IT IS,
I'M NOT BUYING IT.
I'M LOOKING AT THIS PICTURE,
AND I'M NOT SOLD.
I'VE NEVER OWNED A BABY DOLL.
YOU'VE SEEN ONE, THOUGH.
SO THAT'S NOT REALLY AN EXCUSE
THAT YOU HAVEN'T HAD ONE.
- YEAH.
- APPARENTLY, YOU'RE ON
THE PHONE WITH YOUR BOYFRIEND
ALMOST EVERY NIGHT.
HAVE YOU LOST YOUR FOCUS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
I HAVEN'T LET MY BOYFRIEND
DISSUADE ME.
I HAVEN'T LOST MY FOCUS.
YOU WANT THIS MORE THAN
YOU WANNA BE
WITH YOUR BOYFRIEND?
ABSOLUTELY.
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT
IT MIGHT COME TO.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHTY, NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
SO NOW WE HAVE THE TASK
OF DECIDING WHICH ONE
OF THESE GIRLS GOES HOME.
JADE.
HER TEARS ARE AS FAKE
AS THAT POSE.
BUT SHE DOES TAKE
RATHER GOOD PHOTOGRAPHS,
ALTHOUGH THE HARDNESS OF HER--
NOT TO MY TASTE.
FURONDA.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT FURONDA
IS THAT SHE--SHE IS PROGRESSING.
SHE STARTED OFF JUST SO BAD,
AND SHE'S REALLY GETTING THERE.
SHE REALLY IS.
BROOKE.
I DO THIS
EVERY WEEK ABOUT BROOKE,
BECAUSE I--THERE'S SOMETHING
ABOUT BROOKE THAT I REALLY LOVE.
I'D LIKE TO KEEP HER IN, 'CAUSE
I THINK SHE'S GOT SOME MAGIC,
BUT I DON'T WANNA
WORRY ABOUT IT.
WELL, WHEN IS IT GONNA--
WHEN IS THE MAGIC GONNA HAPPEN?
I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST CAN'T BEAR TO LET HER GO.
SHE HAD SOMETHING
TOUCH MY HEART SOMEWHERE.
DANIELLE.
THERE HASN'T BEEN
A PHOTOGRAPH, I THINK,
WHICH HAS BEEN WEAK ON HER YET.
YEAH, BUT SHE NEEDS TO LISTEN
AND GET HER GAP CLOSED.
THIS BLACK AND WHITE PICTURE
OF NNENNA--I FEEL IT.
I THINK IT'S SO BEAUTIFUL.
BABY DOLL PHOTO.
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE'S JUST
SITTIN' THERE,
AND THEY PUT THE MAKEUP ON HER,
AND SHE SAYS, "OKAY, WHAT?"
SARA.
I THINK TODAY
IS THE FIRST JUDGING
THAT WE'VE SEEN SARA
WHERE SHE'S STANDING STRAIGHT.
SHE HAD CONFIDENCE.
SHE TALKED TO US WITH AUTHORITY.
NO, SHE'S A REALLY
BRIGHT GIRL, I THINK.
I'M JUST NOT SURE
SHE'S A MODEL, THAT'S ALL.
JOANIE.
I THINK THESE TWO PHOTOGRAPHS
ARE SENSATIONAL.
I THINK JOANIE'S QUITE GREAT.
I THINK--WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU SAY SHE'S IN?
I SAY, "JOANIE'S IN."
♪♪♪
SEVEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME...
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE SIX OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS, JOANIE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
FURONDA.
NNENNA.
THIS NATURAL PICTURE
IS GORGEOUS, BUT THE JUDGES
DIDN'T LIKE THE BABY DOLL.
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T
HAD A DOLL DOESN'T MEAN
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
SARA.
DANIELLE.
YOU'LL GET THEM TEETH DONE?
YOU MEAN, ALL THE WAY,
COMPLETELY CLOSED?
I THINK ALL THE WAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
WILL JADE AND BROOKE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE, PACK
YOUR BELONGINGS AND GO HOME.
JADE, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
NOT BECAUSE OF BAD PICTURES,
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I SAW
WHEN YOU WERE TEARIN' UP?
WHAT?
SOMEBODY THAT WAS VERY...
FAKE.
NO MATTER HOW BEAUTIFUL
A PICTURE IS,
THE PUBLIC'S NOT GONNA
FALL IN LOVE WITH SOMEBODY
THAT'S ARROGANT
OR DEFENSIVE OR FAKE.
I'M NOT.
BROOKE...
THE JUDGES LOOK AT YOU,
AND EVERY WEEK,
YOU'RE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRL
TO THEM HERE.
WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
IN A PICTURE, AND THE JUDGES
HAVE KEPT YOU AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME, SAYING,
"MAYBE IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
MAYBE IT'S GONNA HAPPEN.
GIVE HER ANOTHER CHANCE.
GIVE HER ANOTHER CHANCE."
NO MORE CHANCES, BROOKE.
I'M SORRY.
♪♪♪
TYRA...
I REALLY--I REALLY DID
FEEL THE PICTURE.
HONESTLY, IT WAS NO FAKE.
BUT PEOPLE ALWAYS CONFUSE
WHAT YOU'RE GIVING
AS SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU HAVE TO GET IN TOUCH
WITH YOUR EMOTIONS AND HOPE
THAT WHAT YOU'RE FEELING
IS WHAT YOU ARE PORTRAYING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, BROOKE.
♪♪♪
IT'S KINDA SAD
THAT I'M LEAVING EVERYBODY.
I COULD HAVE DONE BETTER
THAN I DID IN MY PICTURES
BECAUSE I DO FEEL LIKE
I HAVE A LOT OF POTENTIAL,
AND I JUST FEEL
I KINDA FELL SHORT
IN THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
I WENT INTO ELIMINATION
THINKING, YOU KNOW,
"NO MATTER WHAT,
IF I DO GO HOME,
I'M NOT GONNA CRY."
BY ME CRYING
AND BEING EMOTIONAL,
IT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE ANYTHING.
I'M STILL GONNA BE ELIMINATED.
I'M STILL GOING HOME.
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
SARA FEELS PRESSURED
TO PROVE HERSELF...
MY DESIRE'S BEEN QUESTIONED.
I HATE HEARING THAT.
You just have to go
the extra mile.
AND DANIELLE WEIGHS
A DIFFICULT PERSONAL DECISION.
I DON'T WANNA BE, LIKE,
ASHAMED TO SMILE.
WE WANNA MAKE YOU HAPPY.
- WE WANT YOU TO LOOK FIERCE.
- RIGHT.
AND THE GIRLS GET READY
TO PACK THEIR BAGS.
(cheering)
♪♪♪